plus de quarante ans que la procréation
médicalement assistée divise la france
cette technique médicale soulève des
questions éthiques en fait le point sur
les détracteurs de la pm le premier
opposant c'est l'église
en 1982 elle dénonce l insémination à
l'encontre des lois de la nature à la
naissance du premier bébé éprouvette
elle s'est mobilisée comme le racontait
en 2007 rené frydman
l'un des deux paires scientifique de la
première fécondation in vitro
il y avait une opposition religieuse
surtout au niveau du vatican qui est
même interdit un certain nombre
d'hôpitaux de pratiquer cette technique
la classe politique elle s'écharpent sur
le sujet depuis des décennies je vais
pas vous faire un scoop
en ce qui me concerne sur le principe
même de la procréation médicalement
assistée janish est pas favorable
certains avis peuvent étonner comme
celui exprimé par daniel cohn bendit en
1998 et sur la procréation médicale
jeudi arrêter si on ne peut pas avoir
des enfants ce qui peut arriver à tout
le monde on peut adopter des enfants
verte
la pma divise les médecins elle divise
aussi la population point d'orgue de la
crispation le débat sur le mariage pour
tous promis par françois hollande en
roger accompagnée de l'ouverture de la
pme aux couples de femmes
un enfant pour se développer à dans la
mesure du possible autant besoin de sa
mère que de son père hélas cela
reviendrait à décider d'une façon légale
froide et scientifique que le certains
enfants n'auront plus de père cet
argument est repris tout au long des
manifestations contre le mariage pour
tous un enfant sera considérée un être
humain comme menée de deux femmes ou
bien de deux hommes
donc au nom de l'égalité n'est pas
possible qu'on crée une nouvelle
catégorie d'êtres humains la majorité
socialiste a renoncé à inclure la pme
dans le projet de mariage homo
mais la manif pour tous continuent à
combattre toute forme de procréation non
naturelle mais je suis totalement contre
côté femmes sol arrivant après la
ménopause le dessus tout d'un coup avoir
un enfant très bien elles ont qu'à aller
voir le boulanger du coin ça leur fait
plaisir
et ben non il faut que ça soit mes
impôts qui payent une forte création
assistée
au nom de quoi au nom de quoi la pma
revient dans le débat en 2018 c'était
une promesse de campagne d'emmanuel
macron depuis la manif pour tous ressort
les drapeaux
[Musique]